l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati sul turbo
di smog
vedete che su tutti ma non c'è l'online
di questo gioco sarebbe veramente una
figata ora che ci penso solo che non c'è
perché in realtà gli sviluppatori un po
la mamma [ __ ] ce l'hanno mi ero
anche dimenticato eravamo rimasti con
pietro sul divano effettivamente ma poi
è questa scusate fermi non ho capito
vai piano che voglio vederti è
schiantato contro la prima macchina
quella che vuole che mira a che mira
cioè io c'ho un talento per uccidere
pietro non so come mai c'è la precisione
allucinante anche loro c'era il nostro
talento credo perché ci dovrebbe essere
la poule a voi con uno schema sono tutti
lì parcheggiate occhio occhio occhio
vabbè proviamo col carrello l'obiettivo
è riuscire ad arrivare alla fine prima
che la cura ci prenda strade boni boni
da debbo è va beh
e va beh allora che board occhio piano
piano piano piano piano sono morto in tv
tumblr perché si chiama tumblr vai
pietro turca sul tumblr farvi vedere che
ci sei
ho già evitato una macchina per miracolo
boni che ho fatto a perché sto guidando
male occhio ci sono
che culo che culo incredibile è arrivato
ammettono dal precipizio non so
cos'altro è non vale comunque come
vittoria deve arrivarci intatto
l'aspetto che prova a prendere la
macchina un po più power di questa
provate a prendermi adesso luridi se va
beh allora c'era c'era il muro ecco
perché non sono cascato
era molto più semplice del previsto una
cosa molto si può fare ma ci sono anche
gli usa ma ci sono gli ostacoli la
mettiamo le rampe ai poliziotti
praticamente proviamo così ragazzi non
mi prometto niente ho fatto un po di
ostacoli non li metto mai però stavolta
li faccio venire
guardali sono il padre come che non
avevo mai provato il turbo sono un pirla
e bellissimo
beh qualcosa mi dice che non sta proprio
benissimo infatti a provare il turbo con
la ferrari per curiosità e all'uso per
capire la profonda dal massimo termine
dovevo capire cosa c'è fuori
ok se va bene va bene ok
qualcosa mi dice che forse ho esagerato
un pelo però vabbè stato così sta
incrociando una palma ama il turbo cielo
anche tipo con lo skate board no vabbè
ma a saperlo prima sarebbe stata una
figata
ma li mortacci di eto'o sorella sta
funzionando sì mi sa che funziona anche
un pochettino quello sempre jalo tony
hawk's pro skater in toni pietro pro
skating poi vedere applicato se riescono
a prendermi è quella la curiosità
vai full speed non mi prendere perfetto
sono curiosissimo non so se ce la fanno
o ciò che a quanto vasto skate vai vai
vai vai vai veloce mi sa che ce la fanno
peccato ci ho creduto al divano può
andare più veloce di così
no è no eh e allora c'è proprio la mamma
[ __ ] allora non mi ha avuto giusto
vai vai vai zio non di là bene bene
occhio e il divano visiva no non è
proprio velocissimo un po come lo skate
stai bene e bellissima
chi di noi non vorrebbe avere un casino
parcheggiarla a milano soprattutto però
è veramente [ __ ] ci passo sa di no vabbè
ragazzi che abbiamo ma perché questa
l'ho provata fin troppo probabilmente
[ __ ] le ghiere way devo scappare dalla
banca o rapinato la banca devo scappare
ok da slow e vabbè mi chiama n'attimo
vai vai vai veloce perfetto grande
pietro un passo avanti a tutti ho
parlato troppo presto la madonna ha
fatto un casino cava accada usare un
mezzo di locomozione un po più easy tipo
questo quanto è bello il carano nato da
uno a mille ciao cannes almeno se ne
sbatte proprio le balle delle macchine
sarebbe ancora di fico se potesse
sparare per ora vale come come incastro
eccolo lì cioè che sta andando
ma perché chi si è schiantato nel
parquet ma fai un giro decente del gal
burqa vacca e bacio il carro armato
negano potete fare tanto fare una rapina
con una macchina da autoscontro è
fantastico cioè un obiettivo della vita
secondo me oggi ecco perfetto scavone
uscita e vabbè allora non siamo neanche
usciti dal parcheggio buono così va dai
ragazzi fanno un altra roba invece che
la rapina o questo me lo ricordo
bellissimo
una gara che a questa finale devo fare
il parcheggio se non so se avete capito
proviamo col carrello amico all'operato
del parcheggio ci devo parcheggiare
fantastico il parcheggio era bellissima
la cosa con la macchina decente
parcheggi in ferrari ragazzi oggi fa
vige vi fa vedere come si parcheggia
prestate attenzione
ecco no non è esattamente così però è
questo video mi conferisce patente
lo chiedono non si sono a il posto di
blocco noah geniale dovranno fare con
una macchina che non ho mai usato questo
la bandit facendo la vicina al cartello
tipo stile americano
un'altra e va beh
e vabbè che casini c'è anche il treno è
bellissimo
posso passare anche sulle rotaie
immagino togliti togliti togliti non
posso passare e va beh sono qui avete
sbagliato il treno andato giù capisco
prova a usare un po più di tempismo
se siete d'accordo anche proprio
un'altra strada ancora porca vacca tipo
in gta questo prova l'ultima ragazzi
giusto per curiosità vedere che succede
ma è proprio curiosità è carità cosa
succede se sfondi un posto di blocco col
triciclo e per la scienza che sta
facendo
no no fermo fammi arrivare al posto di
bavero sfondiamo guarda la fonia uguale
non lo sfondo
ecco la moto non vedere se riesco a
saltarlo così sarebbe troppo epico ma il
signore iddio ci credo io ci credo
gli olo eh vabbè c'è bastava anche un po
meno però va bene lo stesso
secondo me la polizia quando mi trova
raga ci riproviamo prova a saltarlo col
anno hanno messo la la rampa che idiota
nave ci provo lo stesso ci avevo creduto
sono rimasto col volante in mano però
c'è se non riesco ad esso non riesco più
impossibile media potente ma neanche
ma la madonna ma come fai a fare un
salto così porca vacca che mira c'è la
precisione allucinata mall chase cos'è
un inseguimento all'inseguimento al
supermercato token berg questa non
l'avevo ancora provato questa era
proprio quello dei vecchi tempi per chi
seguiva turbo di smonta i tempi ce la
sta macchina che era bellissima
ultim'ora e la migliore per sfuggire
dalla polizia
guardali guardali tutti uccellati nel
vero senza una parola guarda guarda non
mi prendo il mite neanche lupin un genio
ma crescono ma no dai perché hai fatto
questo è stato geniale lo riprendevano
mai è stato bellissimo
ditemi voi siano nell'inseguimento più
bello del mondo dei deficienti è rimasto
solo uno non fa cagare che e rimasto
solo questo quanto slittano e niente di
fan talmente bene che si deve far
prendere si è stata giocata bowling e
durata di che l'altra e non ho capito
ancora cos'è sta roba qua però non
proviamo la quale stava proprio la prima
giocata allo anche vinta secondo me a
ecco volevo provare un ottimo questa
però con con i turchi che non aveva
messo l'ultima volta ma il pride turbo e
turbigo 9 dritto dritto e dritto
perfetto secondo me faccio di più di 160
stavolta 170 normale proviene pianissimo
prova per prendere anche il turbo quello
pro preso bene però è difficile
[Musica]
la madonna mi chiamo fattori di 182
addirittura 190 meli che a volte non
basta andare solo veloce che figata
questi storm train oh mio dio a posso
entrare nel consiglio pocho
no devo provare a fare questa cosa
provasse lì sul camion impossibile ma ci
devo provare assolutamente troppo presto
ci proviamo poi ci sono ci sono porca
vacca quasi eccolo arca vacca è
impossibile ragazze se riesco veramente
un genio dovrei essere io ho la
coordinazione paurosa porca vacca cielo
creduto si skin la gara calma ricordo
questa c'è veramente con tutto l'amore
del mondo no
e stato bello si fa la gara con quello
la marca vacca però lui è intelligente
perché fa il giro che alla fine ha vinto
lui comunque si ferma anche davanti a me
per spostarmi ecco questa velocità
giusta mi sento pari pari pari
guardali guardalinee ma che gara cavalca
che schifo
potrei andare più veloce pietro ma io
fammi capire vado dritto sterzo sono
meglio
occhio a non stimolato hanno sterzato
non ci credo io ho evitato l'incidente
mondiale proprio a piegare a bachega
rava che gara bilanciatissima tensione
la gara giusta novi addio mi ha superato
come ma dai ma mi chiama sfingi nonno
madama che ha vinto lui pensate che
disastro ci fa il giro per bene bravo
cose i ragazzi mi è piaciuto mi piace
quali sono le descrizioni sono sacrifici
che non ci vediamo poco seguito da
ragazzi
[Musica]